the first season of HBO's Watchmen has
proven to be complex riveting and
sometimes a little bit confusing it's
impossible for a story like this to not
end with some unanswered questions so
here are the biggest ones we came away
with warning like having a conversation
with dr. Manhattan you will be spoiled
Adrian Veidt spends almost a decade
essentially imprisoned on Europa we see
his time there throughout the season
interspersed with events in Tulsa by the
season finale it's clear what's going on
in Oklahoma is not happening at the same
time as veidt's adventures on Jupiter's
most lively moon the proof is the golden
statue of Veidt that Angela a bar and
Laurie Blake noticed when they interview
lady true Laurie comments on how old he
looks in the recreation and it's because
it's not a statue when true sends a ship
to rescue Veidt from Europa
he's preserved for the trip by being
encased in a golden shell and the
instructions he's given insist he put
his hands on his hips before the
procedure true clearly keeps him on
display for a while before reviving him
just in time to show him her master plan
in action just how long is not entirely
clear when dr. Manhattan teleports
Adrian Veidt Laurie Blake and Looking
Glass
- Veidt space in Antarctica it doesn't
take much for Veidt to convince the
others that Lady trues plan to become
the next dr. Manhattan needs to be
stopped
Veidt says his daughter won't actually
save the world as she claims because he
is clearly a raging narcissist whose
ambition knows no limits its use literal
human true definitely does seem to fit
that bill she doesn't hesitate to kill
the leaders of the cavalry and doesn't
seem the least bit shaken she's
dishonest manipulative and ruthless yet
all those things could be said about
Veidt who does genuinely hope to save
humanity with his act of genocide at the
end of the original comic book series
takes one to know one it could be that
if throughs plan had worked she could
have become some awful dictator it's
also possible that true would have done
exactly what she said and used her new
powers to make the world a better place
it's kind of what her dad did right in
episode 4 Angela and her sister night
guys
chases down a costumed figure who douses
himself in oil drops to the pavement and
slides away into a storm drain the
audience's reaction seemed to be pretty
similar to Angela's viewers had to be
expecting to get some sort of
explanation or at least a clue as to who
this mysterious lube man was in the
finale but he wasn't even mentioned the
show's creators did offer some clue as
to his identity though HBO has been
publishing supplemental materials on its
website under the title PT pedia written
in the world of the show by FBI agent
Dale PD the last entry isn't credited to
PD however it's credited to an FBI
deputy director who explains that PD is
no longer employed by the FBI because of
his obsession with masked vigilantes and
his meandering reports among the
possessions removed from his office a
jug of what appears to be some kind of
canola oil when we first meet Will
Reeves he's over 100 years old retired
from his secret life as who did justice
but spurred back to action after meeting
dr. Manhattan for someone who's lived
for over a century he's in miraculously
good health even though he claims to be
wheelchair-bound at first we eventually
learned he's perfectly capable of
walking all on his own the most obvious
answer to how Reeves is in such good
health is lady true
she's a scientific genius who has no
compunctions about using unconventional
methods to achieve her goals
someone like true seems more than
capable of keeping a man alive and
healthy longer than most or maybe who
did justice is just made of stronger
stuff than the rest of us at first the
message from dr. Manhattan that will
relays to Angela in the movie theater
seems like nonsense
you can make it out without breaking a
couple days
what the hell's that supposed to mean
but when Angela goes to clean up the egg
carton she slammed on the kitchen floor
during her argument with John she
remembers John telling her watch the
eggs lo and behold one egg remains
unbroken during Angela's first meeting
with John he explained he could transfer
his power into an egg that would grant
someone else who ate it his abilities I
suppose I could transfer my atomic
components into some sort of organic
material Angela takes the egg to her
backyard and downs it she slowly reaches
out to the water of her pool to see if
she'll be able to walk on water like
John then the screen goes black will
Angela be the new dr. Manhattan we're
intentionally left in the dark on that
question upon his return to earth Adrian
Veidt isn't met with the praise and
forgiveness he expects may I ask you
what everybody thinks happened to him
armed with the recordings Veidt made for
president Robert Redford Laurie Blake
and Looking Glass insists on a resting
fight for his crimes Veidt laughs at the
idea but Looking Glass knocks him out
cold
assuming they return to the US with
Veidt and the proof of his crimes the
whole world will presumably learn the
piece forged after what was thought to
be an assault by extra-dimensional
aliens was a lie and that the u.s.
president was secretly handpicked from
the shadows will the Cold War reignite
or alternatively will veidt's recordings
prove more effective than Rorschach's
journal will most people find the
revelations too fantastic to be true and
ignore them as crazy conspiracy theories
many of these questions could be
answered in a second season of Watchmen
but show creator Damon Lindelof has said
repeatedly he wants the first season to
tell one self-contained story just as
the original comic series did he hasn't
completely ruled out future seasons
though he seems adamant he won't be a
part of it unless there's another story
he eventually wants to tell in the world
of watchmen he also says he's open to
the idea of stepping back and letting
someone else tackle another season so
will there be a sea
two of Watchmen you avoided answering by
saying nothing ever ends check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite shows are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the belt
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]